elle commence au coeur de la ville et
fini sa trajectoire en pleine campagne
la rue joseph bédier de saint-andré est
bien connu des sportifs à cause de sa
piscine et de son stade
elle abrite aussi le collège joseph
bédier mais de ce grand homme
quels souvenirs reste-t-il qui était je
vais l'aider
même moi comme j'habite pas à
saint-andré moi même j'ai pas souvenir
de joseph étudiant c'est un homme assez
fiable quand même c'est un maillage
avoir un métier avec les relégations
fondateur
collages où vous pouvez écrire un
spécialiste de linguistique si je me
trompe pas
charles marie joseph bédier naît à paris
en janvier 1864 alors que ses parents
ils sont en voyage il perd son père très
jeune et c'est le second mari de sa mère
qui l'adoptent et le choix après ses
études secondaires à saint denis
il prend la direction du lycée louis le
grand puis de l'école normale supérieure
il en sort agrégé de lettres à 22 ans
disciple de gaston parisse du collège de
france ce précoce professeur enseigne la
littérature médiévale à l'université
tout en préparant une thèse dans
laquelle ils démontent les théories
existantes sur l'origine des fabliaux du
moyen-âge en 1893 il n'a pas encore 30
ans mais l'école normale supérieure
l'appelle déjà à 39 ans après le décès
de gaston paris s'il leur en place au
collège de france
toujours passionné de littérature
médiévale il se penche sur l'origine des
légendes épique nouvelle révolution
il démontre qu elle ne raconte pas d
événement historique mais qu'elles sont
des oeuvres de commande pour promouvoir
des itinéraires de pèlerinage en 1920 il
est élu à l'académie française au
fauteuil d'edmond rostand
entre temps il a largement contribué à
l'effort de propagande française contre
l'allemagne pendant la première guerre
mondiale
en 1917 il reçoit même la grand croix de
la légion d'honneur
le 31 août 1938 la mort du meilleur
médiéviste français est annoncé dans la
presse locale